Let's go back to the display message
method that we were looking at earlier.
We were trying to figure out what
exactly is going on in here.
>From what we've learned so far it looks
like there's a TextView object, and
the variable name is called
orderSummaryTextView.
Then it says a bunch of code
that we don't really recognize.
But on the next line, we use that
variable prderSummaryTextView, and
we try to set the text on
it to be this message.
Let's find out more about how to
call methods like this on objects.
When we call method on object
it has to follow this format.
First we write the Object Variable Name
in this case it's titleTextView
then we add a.
Then it's followed by the method name,
which is setText, in this case.
This method is defined exactly this
way in the TextView Java class.
The method declaration also specifies
that there's an input parameter
of a string, so we put parentheses and
then pass in a string as input.
Then, we end the statement
with a semicolon.
When you write this line of code,
it modifies the titleTextView object so
that it displays this on the screen.
The reason we use the object
variable name here,
is because there could be
multiple TextViews in your app.
So make sure you're calling the method
on the right object instance.
When you're specifying input
arguments make sure you're specifying
the right arguments in the right order
according to the method declaration.
So if there's no inputs, you would
just have an empty set of parentheses.
The way we pass inputs to a method
is the same as we learned earlier in
lesson three.
And remember to separate
the object variable name and
the method name with this dot.
Here's another example,
on that same titleTextView object,
We're going to call
a setTextSize method on it.
This method takes an integer as
input for the new text size.
So in this case,
we just pass 18 as the next text size.
When the Android device
executes this line of code,
it's going to change this titleTextView
to have a larger font size of 18.
In this example,
we're calling a method on the TextView
object that is called warningTextView.
The method is called setTextColor,
and it takes as input a new color.
Notice that the color is
specified as Color.RED.
So if we look at the documentation for
the color class then, we can scroll
down and see that red is defined here.
There are a bunch of other colors
that you can use here as well.
So, when you call a setTextColor, you
could call Color.BLUE or Color.BLACK.
And lastly, here is an example of
calling a method on an ImageView.
This ImageView object has a variable
name of welcomeImageView, and
we call the method
setImageResource on it.
This method takes as input the new image
that we should set on this ImageView.
We specify the new image as a resource
ID, in the format of R.drawable.
And this is the file name,
this is just another use case of
using resource IDs in Java code.
To get the full list of methods that
you can call on a TextView object,
just open up the TextView Android
documentation page.
You can get to it by just searching for
TextView Android and clicking here.
This is a page we already recognize, and
we already know about the XML attributes
that are listed on this page.
If I scroll down further then I can
see a list of all the public methods
in the text view class.
If you want to find something,
you can just use Cmd+F, or
Ctrl+F if you're on Windows.
I'm going to look for the setTextColor
method which we used earlier.
Here's the setTextColor method and
it takes an integer
color as an input param.
All these methods were declared as
public methods in the TextView class.
That's why we can call
these methods now.
If they were declared
as private methods,
we wouldn't see them show up here.
When you're calling these methods,
make sure you're checking what input
parameters it requires and you're
passing in the inputs in the correct
order and of the correct data type.
When you're looking at code,
sometimes you might not see the dot
notation when calling methods.
The difference matters whether you're
inside a class or outside of a class.
Let's look at an example
within the TextView class.
We have the setText method defined,
as well as some other method.
Say that you want to call the setText
method from this other method.
You can do so by calling setText and
then passing in the input param.
But where's the dot and
where's the object variable name?
Well this line of is actually sort for
this.setText("Hello").
This refers to the current
object instance and
then setText is being
called on this object.
This is a format we're more familiar
with for calling methods on objects.
However the this.part is implied and
it's optional,
o to make our code more concise,
we can just call setText("Hello).
So notice the difference between
calling setTexts within the class and
calling setTexts outside of that class.
When you think about it,
this makes more sense,
because it's very clear which
TextView you want to set the text on,
in case you have multiple
TextViews within this class.
Here's another difference between
bring inside the TextView class,
versus being outside
of the TextView class.
Within the TextView class,
you can access private variables and
private methods.
If you're outside of the TextView class,
you can't use methods that are private
and you can't access private variables.
Within the MainActivity class,
you can only access public methods and
public variables from
the TextView class.